I have guests that regret coming here
I'm Greg Alva it's not me hey I thought
of the rare cases of a yes and and that
I'm glad to not get yes and it this is
Juliet's row so it's French
whoa that's intense
I met Juliet there John Campea she's a
filmmaker model follow her on Instagram
check out her twitch channel ABC looper
the channel I have seen the channel
looper the channel so that's cinematic
we're gonna watch movie scenes that
actors regret doing I can think of a few
the videos a little bit old let's see
the regrets these actors have and let's
laugh at them alright good yeah yeah
seriously there's not the emotional
damage you get the physical brain yeah
alright let's do this
acting is a profession that requires a
lot of versatility and willingness to
test boundaries here are the movies
means that actors regret doing a titanic
run maybe the most she regretted the
Titanic is the one what goes wrong
character asks Leonardo DiCaprio's jack
to draw me like one of your french girls
it's a passionate moment showing her
character overcoming the disapproval of
her fiance and mother to claim her own
agency and embrace the man she's fallen
in love with is paying customer does
this look like a BBC show naked home
she'd love for that to stuff Yahoo's
Megatron quote I don't find that future
it feels very uncomfortable why would
you do that
end quote why indeed I got up give that
man a shirt
and you thought about you're doing this
examine our worries now that his pecs
might overshadow is acting he told a
show be they definitely not very
realistic I certainly won't be asking to
do it though and quote a change of heart
in the 2013 action comedy kick ass to
Jim Carrey plays a superhero called
Colonel stars and stripes whose
gruesomely murdered by supervillains a
few months after the film was released
Carey publicly condemned the level of
violence remember that really a new part
in the aftermath of the tragic Sandy
Hook massacre
would you ever after he'd wrapped up
doing his scenes quote I did have your
gas to a month before Sandy Hook and now
in all good conscience I could not
support that level of violence I am not
ashamed of it but recent events have
caused a change in my heart interesting
Wow look at those responses pictures
probably wish Kerry had figured that out
before it's a great movie though enjoy
to eat drugs sex passengers is a science
fiction adventure starring Jennifer
Lawrence and Chris Pratt
despite the star power of its cast it
didn't do very well at the box office
backlash against a crucial plot point
that involves a startling disregard for
the consent and personal autonomy of one
of the characters which boy by Jennifer
I did not say those emails bet the sex
seems too drunk to remember doing them
she told CNN she had jitters about the
shoot because it was going to be her
first time filming a sexy and also felt
guilty about doing so with Pratt who was
married quote I got really drunk but
that led to more anxiety because I was
like what have I done
No Oh No it's time kissing a married man
and the guilt is the worst feeling in
your stomach Wow
that leg thrust I heard she didn't know
about this it's a certain extent let's
see if Liberty iconic scene where by
simply on crossing her legs and hmm
flashing the cash during a police
interrogation she completely reverses
the balance of power it's nice
[Music]
which is sort of ironic because relation
and a violation of consent Stone claimed
she was asked by director Paul Verhoeven
to remove her underwear because the
flashes of light were messing up the
shot that's what it was until she saw
the finished film oh yeah people he
responded by slapping for heaven who has
publicly denied stones claims saying
while I oh my there is a wall there okay
to Menace Terence Stamp plays whose
uttered out in favor of the secrets of
mortality they're not the only actor who
however only actually arrived on set
Portman was nowhere in sight and stamp
was directed to aim his dialogue towards
a piece of paper Oh No oh it was just
pretty boring which not coincidentally
also sums up the entire movie what a
bummer poor dude I love how this list
went from like sexy and edgy to a dude
didn't get to a finale for Kate Winslet
scene
I can only emit this video is a little
bit old but I feel let me speak for a
woman here okay as a man I feel like I
have every right to interject here I
don't know what you go through in terms
of your own end of like social media and
like modeling on Instagram but my
friends the people I've met who have
done like mainly like bikini modeling or
something like that they constantly are
hit up all the time and just sent really
degrading erotic you know images I'm
putting it very lightly yeah I feel like
just being an actress or some or a woman
on the internet you already lends itself
to that so didn't note that Holly was
history that women have gone through
that terribly being degraded so I can
imagine the 90s for Kate Winslet to have
done this for the longest time the most
famous movie of all
I'm to be approached like that had to
have these photos on hand of her draw
naked or nude and be asked to sign that
yeah I can I can get why that's
insulting I'm not entirely surprised
there no no it's such an iconic scene so
memorable and I don't think you know
it's very possible that a lot of those
people didn't mean anything pervy or
wrong by it but I understand how that
would be extremely uncomfortable don't
defend the men all right well I'm sure
it's not only men that we're asking for
the I say it is okay it's just an iconic
moment that's true that's wrong is it
the most famous scene of the movie
probably is it I thought it was like the
ice everyone says that like even if
you've never seen the movie you know
that line like better than any other
line from the film I guarantee you guys
mean if I said that to my girlfriend she
would be like what the hell are you
talking to know what I'm referring I
would say drama I like that chick who
got it on the hit on the IMS I'll line
up all right Taylor Lautner I got to
tell you man
I think Taylor Lautner to me is so
amusing because I don't think he's very
a very good actor that being said I
really enjoy watching
he's like early days Channing Tatum to
me you're so good-looking
you're so chiseled and ripped and you're
so confident that I don't care you're
doing a bad job I'm so amused for
watching I loved watching him in those
Twilight movies even though I'm like
he's not doing really good I still find
it very entertaining I mean what do you
think that they they have a solid point
here at tail on has this all point I
think he has a solid point I'm pretty
sure that's not the only films he was
ever hurt listen I think he went on to
be shirtless in other films anyway and
if you remember that time have you seen
the Twilight movies I've seen the first
one I actually haven't seen all of them
you haven't seen the second Twilight but
that's worse he really takes you sure oh
my god they're a guilty pleasure of mine
so he says when really they're just a
fan favorite there was all that talk
about it cuz they were gonna recast him
really because yet Jacob
was named jacob in the books he becomes
like six feet tall and it's like a
totally different human being and tail
honor didn't want to lose out on the
role so he got a sanely jacked to earn
the rollbacks they were unlike if you
get jack will keep you they were gonna
recast him and so he earned that role so
i think there's so much attention
surrounding his his body yeah it's not
okay to degrade men no mean woman
there's no idea what it's like yeah
that's true
I mean he's got residuals for life yeah
it's funny looking at this old video
because Jim Carrey has exponentially
evolved to rather philosophical
esoteric existential kind of mindset I'm
a guy I can't imagine him ever being in
a kick-ass movie like that again totally
forgot he was in that
so I'm he's been a long time since I've
watched those films but I totally and he
was good in it which is weird yeah you
know for the guy who like refused to
promote his own movie he was certain he
was actually really good in it but he'll
do a movie like sonic where he plays an
evil scientist not not okay not okay Jim
hypocrisy I say hit the crib passengers
you didn't see that yeah I haven't seen
it just because I heard it did something
terribly happen yeah I didn't see it
either I did I had no idea there were
sex scenes in that film speed you 13
yeah yeah I'm like what's the big deal
about sex scene if it's pg-13 but then
you find out I mean that's pretty
interesting that she was talking about
being uncomfortable he's a married man
I'm not surprised she seems to have such
a heart of gold that's true you can
always tell a person really is that
Basic Instinct month is probably most
shocking one to me yeah if that's all
true
that's it's such a famous scene that is
the most famous scene from everybody
yeah it's a shocking scene like I only
watch somebody for the first time a
couple years ago and I didn't actually
know about that scene like III heard
about it I didn't realize you actually
you know
sheeeit so when i saw that i was
actually surprised and to find out that
she didn't of according to her
mortifying yeah first time she saw that
scene was in a room like full of people
mortifying wonder if it was at the
premiere when they say that she slapped
director absolutely sure yeah
but she's also made a lot of money since
good so what does it come down to julia
is it okay to be degraded if you're
gonna make a lot of money i mean it
depends on what you want to the person
what are you okay whenever know how to
answer these i love it
me personally know there you go some
people don't care so no i don't think it
was okay at all but she's great in the
film yes overall but really the one that
stands out is the controversial Terence
Stamp not being able to have a scene
with Natalie Portman oh my god when I
watched that movie I was like is she
there with her or not it is a paper
what is he talking to you I don't feel
like they're in the same room so I'm
glad looper clarify that for us oh my
god
I mean I meet people all the time out
here who want to work with an actor in
something and so they agree to it and
then they don't even get a have a scene
with that person so I mean you kind of
have to expect that that's true that's
going into films schedule around stupid
things all the time well guys what
number what what good story here that
see the wheel yeah we don't have going
forward for YouTube questions subscribe
to looper subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification about follow
Juliet on Instagram and twitch as soon
as you can she deserves it she needs it
she'll say I do and let's end this with
a patron of the nation
Kameron fresh wheelie camera French what
can I say about this guy well first off
I need to inform you dude you asked me
to give a message to John Roca and
Kristian harloff didn't give that
message to harloff because I haven't
seen him since that message but told
Roca when he was here what you said and
he had no clue what the hell I was
talking about you don't need to worry
about apologizing to him Freddie thank
you but I tried reminding him either way
he says thanks secondly Cameron French
for the longest time has been a great
correspondent and helping us out with
discovering some movie news and forming
us updating us and he knows some great
videos our way waiting a long time he
finally launched his own blog like page
you should go check out his Instagram
Cameron's movie reviews yeah he is
incredibly knowledgeable with film if
you guys have stayed around the video
this long clearly you have some kind of
investment in let's go show your support
to him there's a link in the description
box is one of the featured links in the
pin comment please go show your support
to Cameron French and this one sincerely
just for you buddy